faut réussir moi ce que je veux c'est
réussir si je réussis à Lille ou à
Saint-Étienne ou je sais pas dans
n'importe quel club moi ce que je veux
c'est jouer en D1 quoi
[Musique]
c'est l'histoire d'un banlieusard de la
ville des Ulis émigré en Principauté de
Monaco en quelques années Thierry Henry
réalise le rêve de tout jeune
footballeur côtoyer le plus haut niveau
il passe des HLM aux frasques monégasque
du football de rue au football en herbe
histoire d'un transfert réussi
[Musique]
entre les mains il a des qualités que
que beaucoup voudraient à lui de
travailler de continuer vers l'avant il
a montré que il a fait quelques matchs
en pro cette année à 17 ans c'est très
très intéressant bon il faut qu'il
s'impose il faut qu'il ne faut pas qu'il
s'arrête là
Thierry Henry est né aux Ulis en 1977
l'année de naissance de la ville
estonienne il commence à jeune carrière
au club omnisport des Ulis en poussant
je vois pas les os puis à Versailles
avant de s'essayer à Viry-Châtillon lors
d'un match minime un recruteur de Monaco
venu superviser un autre joueur cadet et
frappé par l'opportunisme du jeune
numéro 9 des Ulis ce jour-là Thierry
Henry marque la bagatelle de 6 buts dans
la même partie deux ans plus tard en
stage à Clairefontaine Monaco en rôle
définitivement Thierry Henry comme
stagiaire professionnel
j'espère jouer dans un club de D2 et
justement faire quelques bons matchs
pour taper dans un club de dance on sait
jamais si je réussis pas ici faut
réussir moi ce que je veux c'est réussir
si je réussis à Lille ou à Saint-Étienne
ou je sais pas dans n'importe quel club
moi ce que je veux c'est jouer en D1
quoi je vais contre jouer en D1 c'est ça
c'est ce que je veux depuis tout petit
et j'espère que je vais y arriver quoi
le 31 août 1994 marque un tournant dans
la jeune carrière de Lucien Arsène
Wenger alors entraîneur de l'AS Monaco
titularis Henry en championnat de
première division aux côtés du Brésilien
Sonia Anderson quelques mois plus tard
c'est Jean-Luc et Tori alors nouvelle
entraîneur qui donne de nouveau sa
chance au talent grandissant de l'avant
centre parisien pour sa 16e sélection en
bleu tirée Henry alors capitaine marque
encore des points il inscrit deux des
cinq buts ici même de la victoire
française contre l'Angleterre la qualité
surtout de de pouvoir éliminer ce que
pour un attaquant considérable il peut
faire la différence balle au pied et il
a aussi un grand potentiel puissance et
capable de passer mal au pied mais
capable aussi de passer en vitesse en
force bon jeu de tête et puis surtout à
mon avis un grand attaquant d'avenir il
faut absolument qu'ils persévère et qui
travaille dans le domaine de la finition
parce que lorsque au bout de ses actions
il y aura la finition on peut considérer
que ça très près du très haut niveau
en montant ces marches Titi comme le
surnomme son père doit se remémorer le
chemin parcouru depuis des terrains
stabilisés de la banlieue parisienne à
la pelouse du stade Louis II Thierry
Henry est en train de se faire une place
sous le soleil monégasque
[Musique]